- Well, hello, everyone.
I'm Yukio Lippit the
faculty director of the Arts
at the Radcliffe Institute.
And it's my real pleasure
to welcome all of you
to this special event, the
opening of an exhibition
by the artist the
Xaviera Simmons,
titled Overlay in the
Johnson-Kulukundis Family
Gallery at Radcliffe.
Now the genesis of the
exhibition by Xaviera Simmon,
that opens today, can be located
in the Institute's desire
to conceive of a show that
resonated with the Radcliffe's
research theme for
the year-- urbanism.
This led us to explore
a collaboration
with the Cambridge
Arts Council, which
had been organizing a series of
installations and performances
by contemporary artists to
celebrate the first remodeling
and revisioning of
the Cambridge Common
in a generation, one that's
curated by Dina Deitsch.
Now this series is organized
under the title the Commons--
Art in the Cambridge Commons
and is slated to begin in May.
And we'll hear more about
this in the conversation
with the artist that follows.
But because the
Radcliffe Institute
is adjacent to the
Cambridge Common,
we wanted to find a
way, an artistic way,
of exploring and opening
up this adjacency
and by extension of opening
up the Institute more
generally to understand
further in ways
that are creative,
imaginative, even surprising--
its resources, its
archives-- of quarrying
further the relationship
of its history
to the contemporary world.
And in this regard, we have
found the ideal collaborator,
Xaviera Simmons, and
feel very fortunate
to be where we are today,
opening the exhibition.
Simmons is a highly
acclaimed artist
whose work dynamically combines
photographs, instillations,
performance, sound, sculpture,
and other multimedia
components.
These various aspects
are placed in kind
of a perpetual symbiotic
relationship in which they
are mutually informing
and enriching and cycling
through one another to
generate remarkable new worlds.
Simmons' artistry is
formally beautiful and highly
crafted in terms of its
formal elements-- composition,
color, scale, and so forth.
And we're convinced that
you'll agree with us when you
enter into the gallery space.
But this remarkable,
formal beauty
is not necessarily the artist's
only or even primary concern.
You might call one of
her primary concerns
the characters, that complex
characters, that she layers
into existence, characters
that are palimpsests
of historical figures and
contemporary concerns placed
within various unlocatable
landscapes, that
are urban, rural, or
natural, and that participate
in open ended
non-linear narratives,
much like actors in a play or
vignette for which the script
is no longer available.
It is because of this ambiguity
that these personations,
as we like to call
them-- accretions
of specific types of
experience and memory
and lived history--
become a springboard
for further
engagement and insight
into the relationship
between what we assume
to be the relationship between
the archive and the past,
how one understands the inner
lives of historical figures,
and ultimately and importantly
the contemporary world itself.
Simmons received a
bachelor in fine arts
from Bard College in 2004.
She completed the Whitney
museum's independent study
program in studio art in
2005 while undertaking
a two-year actor training
conservatory with the Maggie
Flanagan Studio.
And this training in acting
and directing, I think,
is a very important
part of her practice
overall, mutually informing
other aspects of her work.
She's exhibited and performed
in a wide range of major venues,
including the Museum of
Modern Art, PS1, the Studio
Museum in Harlem,
the contemporary arts
museum in Houston, the Public
Art Fund, The Sculpture Center.
She's also the recipient
of many prizes,
including the David Driscoll
prize, the Jerome Foundation
Travel Fellowship, an Arts
Matters Fellowship Smart Power
Fellowship.
In 2012, Simmons was
an artist in residence
at the Studio Museum in Harlem.
And in 2015, she
received the Foundation
for Contemporary Arts Grant.
Now at the Radcliffe Institute,
her exhibition, Overlay,
is rooted in the
stories, images,
and historical narratives
found amidst the archives
of the Radcliffe Institute
Schlesinger Library
on the history of
women in America.
The artist engages with a set
of Schlesinger collections
that resonate with
longstanding explorations--
cookbooks, first person
travel narratives,
images of women at work,
architects, works about health,
among many others.
Simmons distills this
multitude of voices
and places them in a
new contextual space,
overlaying diverse languages
of which there are many,
which you will be
introduced to in the show
in presenting a diverse
cross-section of figures
to enliven and inhabit the
landscape of the gallery.
In doing so, Simmons
not only explores
alternative possibilities for
the figures in the archives,
but repopulates the Schlesinger
itself with new voices.
Now as I mentioned
earlier, Overlay
is part of a collaboration
between the Radcliffe arts
program and the
Cambridge Arts Council,
whose summer series on
the Cambridge Common
will feature a performance
created by Simmons based
on the exhibition.
Now before inviting
the artist on stage
for a discussion
of her work, I'd
like to mention
that we'll be having
a reception after the
discussion for which we will all
move from here to Byerly Hall,
which is where the gallery is
located two buildings down from
here to celebrate the opening
and give you a chance
to experience the show
and meet the artist.
I'd also like to
take the opportunity,
because so many
people were involved
in putting the show
together, to thank,
on behalf of Rebecca Wassarman,
the director of Academic
Ventures, and Meg Rotzel,
our arts program manager,
a number of people who are
crucial to the realization
of this exhibition.
We'd like to thank
Sean Weely, a PhD
candidate in the history
of art department
here at Harvard who was
Xaviera's research assistant
and crucial to the show.
Our gallery proprietor
Joe Zane imbued the show
with his own masterful
artistry in helping
to consummate the installation,
Jennifer Birkhead, who
coordinated virtuosically the
translators and speakers that
are a crucial part
of the show, as well.
I would like to think Deanna
Carey and the Schlesinger
staff who were so
helpful and enabled
so much the research that
went into the personations
that we'll be
witnessing later on,
Benjamin Shaffer, who lent
much of his time and energy
to our efforts and finally
to Xaviera herself, who
along with masterful
artistry and intelligence
brought so much
goodwill and generosity
and enthusiasm to the show
and gave us a new sense
of what it means to
collaborate with an artist.
We are profoundly
grateful to you, Xaviera.
Now our conversation
this evening
will be joined by
Dina Deitsch, who
is the curator of the Commons
Art in the Cambridge commons
and is also the John
R. and Barbara Robinson
family interim director of the
Carpenter Center for the Visual
Arts at Harvard.
Previously she was the
curator of contemporary art
at the deCordova
Sculpture Park and Museum
and has taught and
lectured widely,
including currently as a guest
lecturer at the Massachusetts
College of Art and Design.
And her record of achievement
in the contemporary art world
is extensive.
And she was instrumental in
the organization of the show.
So we're very grateful
to her, and we're
delighted that she'll
participate with us
in this public conversation.
So without further
ado, please join me
in welcoming Deena Deitsch and
our featured artist Xaviera
Simmons to the stage.
- Well, there's so much to
talk about about your show
and your artworks, Xaviera.
And so I wanted to begin
with your experience
with the Radcliffe
Archives itself--
what you focused on, what
caught your attention.
- Hi, everybody.
It's so nice to be
here, of course.
And I'll just
reiterate-- thanks again
to Yukio, Deena, Meg, Sean,
and Becky-- everybody,
Jen, beautiful faces here.
So I'm really
thankful to be here.
So I wanted to say that.
OK, I'm here.
So tell me the question, again.
- Yeah, sure.
The Radcliffe Archives--
what caught your attention?
Tell us about your experiences.
- Yeah, so I had just come off
of doing a project in New York
City first with the high line,
Friends of the High Line,
and then with the
kitchen in New York City.
And in that project
I had been looking
at a lot of archival images.
Archive, that's such a
strange word these days now.
But I had been looking
at a lot of images,
a lot of homoerotic
imagery, a lot of gestures.
I'd also produced my
first choreographic work.
And this is pre-election.
So I came to the
archives thinking
a lot about first gesture still
and then what the Schlesinger
archive had inside of it.
It's a really
first step curious.
And then, for me,
the process goes
that I think about the language
that the archive puts out
there, like what does the
sc advertise of itself,
what does it talk about?
And it talks a lot
about women's things,
like Feminism with a big F or
feminist marches or cooking.
I remember coming in seeing
things about Julia Child,
and then, going a little deeper,
and I saw protest buttons
and then going a little deeper.
And then I saw, oh, wait
there's a huge travel section.
A little deeper-- there's
travel and affluence.
And then there's this
whole section of images.
And then, going a little
deeper, and there's
like these female
photojournalists.
And then, going a little
deeper, and there's
this like amazing BDSM archive
that the Schlesinger collected.
And then going deeper,
and there's porn in there
and constantly going deeper.
And so I started off with
a cursory look, oh, wow--
feminism, protests,
which is pretty deep.
But there's so much in there.
There's really a
beautiful collection
of women and sexuality,
which I was probably really
excited about, I think, because
I had been thinking about that
from my show at the kitchen.
So it just was natural to
look for it along with themes
that I already think about in
my work, which is landscape,
which is what's
underneath landscape
and that American history.
And that's how I begin.
- Could we follow up
on that a little bit?
You have talked
in the past about
the interesting
dialectical relationship
between an archive, which is
so orderly on the outside--
that it's very clean and
arranged in a way, of course
systematically to
allow us to access it--
but that there is this
inherent messiness of the lives
they-- are in.
And you also have
a real interest
in bringing out the
kind of sensuality
of the archive, the
seams that you hit,
which are really
about the inner lives
of the subjects of the archive.
Could you talk a little bit
more about your interest
in these areas?
- I think archives are sort of--
that word.
Every time I say it, I
feel tripped up with it
because I think, in terms
of art making, that's
like one of those buzz words.
So I don't know
how to describe it.
It is an archive technically.
But it's really like collections
of people's items and things.
So I remember one
time Luke [INAUDIBLE]
wrote about my work, about
a series of photographs
that I produced.
And he was like, I see
a lot of dead people,
because I use a lot of
old images and images
from the 70s, 80s 60s in some
of my sculptural photographs.
And so I can't help
but go into an archive
and feel the dead people.
But at the same time, that's
the first layer right.
That's like getting the box
that the library gives you
to research that you ask for.
But then once you start to
go through the contents of so
and so's life--
it's not all dead
people, but a lot--
obviously they
start to come alive.
I looked at a few
different travel
writers and female
journalists, photo journalists.
The first female
photojournalist, her archives
are here.
And you really see
a woman whose life
took her from Cambridge
through all different parts
of the world.
So she started to
become alive to me.
And I just went on
her journey with her.
I was coming here for--
I don't know-- six months.
So I just kept feeling first
the weight of this person
is not here anymore.
And so I'm able to look
through their things,
their private thoughts, their
private images, and then slowly
those private thoughts
started to give me
life in terms of
thinking about making
an exhibition in the space.
- Archive is a difficult word.
It's something more
like a living repository
of memories and experiences that
you are engaging and finding
a lot of future possibility
with in general.
But there's also an
interesting timeline
to your engagement with
the Radcliffe repository
of memories and
experiences, which
is that, when we engaged you
and when Deena engaged you
for the commons project,
it was some time
in the middle of last year.
And since then, the world
has changed quite a bit.
And there is an
interesting relationship
that you've articulated between
your work in the repository,
in these other people's
lives and memories,
in that kind of memory space
and what's going on externally
and how they mutually
inflect one another.
- Yeah I think we
started talking--
I don't remember
what month, Deena--
summer of 2016.
So that was pre where we are.
And I had a certain--
I don't want to say that I
was complacent because I don't
think, as a woman in my body--
a black woman, artist--
I don't know that I'm ever
complacent because it's
a restless space this
being American here, being
a black American here.
So it's a restless space for me.
But I definitely think that the
hairs on every part of my body
have been raised substantially
since the election
of the gentleman.
So I was doing a lot of
research and coming to Cambridge
and coming to the library
and coming to Radcliffe
and interacting
with these archives.
But at the same time,
there were so many things
happening so quickly,
and there are.
We're only 100 days into a
conversation or monologue.
So I couldn't help
but hear both sides,
which is something I was
talking to the students
about earlier today.
There's like two sides.
There's the roots of the
tree and then the leaves
of the tree.
And I guess the archives kind
of like started to become
the roots of the tree.
And then the monologue
and all of its branches
started to be the
tops of the tree.
And that's what started to
happen to me as I was thinking
about the exhibition--
was, well, I
want to maintain the
conversation that we proposed
in the beginning, which was
thinking about the archives
and thinking about how
to distill language
from the archives,
but I also had
to start paying attention
to what was happening here
and also what was
happening here at Harvard.
I was really impressed
with the slavery--
correct me with
the correct term.
- The University and
Slavery Conference.
- University and
So I touch on that
in the exhibition.
And that had to do with
my newfound friendship
with Meg, who told me about it.
And I had to touch on that.
So that's like the branches
right and all the flora
of the tree-- was like what's
happening now actually here.
And then there's
obviously the historical
that had to maintain.
So I think you'll see in
the exhibition there's
like this kind of push and
pull between then and now.
- Xaviera, I wanted to jump in.
I think it's
interesting that image
that you chose for the
marketing and that we're
looking at tonight.
It's not in the show per se.
But I love that this
is the image that
led you to your entire project.
And I'll let you talk about the
installation as you would like.
Or there could be
a great reveal.
But it's interesting
about how you
move through the
cookbooks, the Julia
Child-- we had a lot of
conversations about cookbooks.
I think that was our big draw.
We were like, look at that.
And BDMs, that was a big one.
- BDSM.
- Oh, BDSM, sorry.
Outrageous--
- Outrageous Women.
Does anyone know
Outrageous Women?
It's amazing.
It was produced in Cambridge
from like 1986 to '88,
I believe.
And it's a zeen.
I think there were
only 12 issues.
And the whole stack is in the
library in the Schlesinger
Library.
And it's little thin
pages, but it was right--
I guess it was 80s, but pre
the onslaught of AIDS right.
So it was it women run.
It was a women run sexual
awareness magazine,
specifically dealing with
bondage and Cambridge.
So really, really interesting.
And these women's imaginations--
and it's weird.
I looked up the author
late a while ago.
And there's only
one image of her.
But there's no image.
She has a Facebook page,
but it's like a cat.
So she went from being tying
women up and all this stuff
and writing--
she was the publisher and one
of the writers-- tying women up
to now she's like the cat lady.
I've looked for her.
I'm like, where is it?
She still lives in Cambridge.
She's got cats on her page.
I'm like, ah.
I don't know how you do that.
- So I was wondering
if you might
want to talk about
the image that you
did she choose in a little bit.
Although Cambridge--
and what was it--
bondage and Cambridge will
stay in my mind forever.
The story and the
narrative that you did
end up choosing, which seems
so timely about the moment
we're in and the piece that
you ended up producing.
- So this image is
from Mary McNally,
who was a photographer.
She doesn't have a huge
archive or a huge folder
in the library.
But she has a really substantial
and significant one to me
in that she photographed
a 1980 UN conference.
So I originally thought
the installation
was going to be a lot
about images of travel
and a conversation
about the opportunities
that affluent
women had to travel
and then how to distill that.
But it really became about
looking at these images--
these are two of her images--
looking at her images
and thinking about how powerful
the images were, especially
they were taken in 1980,
and where we were today.
And I couldn't let it go.
I was like, this looks
like an image that was-- it
was right during
the women's march
when I think I made
this photograph.
Or those are not my slides--
but that I decided that
that should be the cover.
Because she really
paid attention
to every single moment
that was happening
during this conference.
So I just thought
of the conference
as the foundation for the
exhibition and as the vessel
to hold all of the
languages and narratives
that I wanted to build
inside of that installation.
- Well, can we talk a
little bit more about that?
Because, again, you have
this interesting relationship
temporarily between
the time frames
of these lives and histories
that you're examining
and then that
contemporary moment.
And this conference
is also something
that resonates with your
understanding of the landscape
of Radcliffe, your experience
of the University and Slavery
Conference.
The exhibition itself takes
on the format of a conference
in a certain sense.
It's a conceit of a conference
through the instrument
and official language of the
conference you promulgate.
Could you could you
say a little bit more
about how you understand the
conference as a landscape
or setting for
your installation?
- That's interesting.
I took the idea
of a conference--
it's weird.
That word conference is another
word like archive I feel--
in my studio practice.
It's very filled with a lot
of bureaucratic language.
And it's very off
putting in a way.
It's so microscopic--
is that the word when
you want to look really close?
It's both microscopic
and macroscopic.
Are those the two words
when you go down and then
when you go out?
Is that microscopic,
macroscopic?
- Well, we understand.
- You know I'm talking about.
So I don't know.
Conferences do both things
simultaneously I find.
I'm not sure that
conferences really come
to any kind of
conclusion-- is the thing.
And so that was really what
I keyed in on-- was I wanted
to make a conference,
which you'll see--
I wanted to begin to construct
a conference that actually
had an opinion, I felt,
that actually came
to some kind of conclusion
and actually promoted society
that I felt was more
progressive in its language
than where we are now and
also where we were in 1980.
So I used her images
as the foundation
to build another conference,
another idea of a conference.
It's still an official
language in terms
of if you read the text.
But I invited 17 speakers,
interpreters, to interpret
the text that I wrote--
so there was like 17
different languages--
so that they could
add another element
to this American landscape,
bringing other languages
to the forefront
that, therefore,
were populating the conference
with a diverse population
of women.
- Can we, maybe just
for the audience,
mention that the sound component
is a very important one
for the exhibition?
And you'll hear,
as Xaviera said,
many different languages,
including Yiddish, Amharic
Yoruba, French, Spanish,
Portuguese, Mandarin, Haitian,
Creole, Jamaican, Patois,
Hebrew, Farsi, Arabic,
Hindi, and Japanese, translated
and spoken by some individuals,
I think, who are in
this room with us today.
This is such a rich and
interesting and remarkable
array of languages.
But could you say a little bit
about the logic of selection?
- Well, first I started thinking
a lot about Trump's travel
ban, the Muslim ban.
And I had to think about Arabic.
I could not let that go.
And I actually talked
a lot about those.
In the text of the conference,
which you'll see on the video,
I actually continuously--
well, I think four
or five times--
put those countries
that he tried to ban--
I don't even know
where we're at--
in the text.
So that's one language set.
And then I have a
personal relationship
to Amharic, which is just
because family member--
really close friends
are from Ethiopia.
I think it's a
language that you don't
hear very often in
America unless you
go to certain enclaves.
I also live with my partner
who speaks four languages--
besides English-- three
languages fluently.
And so I'm constantly
aware of how language--
I've watched him travel.
And when he goes to France, he's
very kind of stiff and tight.
And then, when we travel to
Italy, he's very like loose.
He gets into the--
he uses the language.
And then when he
travels to Spain--
that's his favorite language.
And I know when
he speaks Spanish,
that that's the
one that feels most
passionate and sensual to him.
And so I carry that with
me in a lot of my work.
And actually my
first projects that
were multilingual I used him
as the model for the project.
So I like hearing
multiple languages.
I think Yoruba-- one
out of every seven
African on the continent
is born in Nigeria.
So I really thought it
was important to have
Yoruba in the dialogue.
each: country in Africa
has 20 different dialects.
I can't own them all.
But I could try to put
some of them in there.
Then, it was important for me
to have a language like Yiddish
because I kept asking everyone
who speaks Yiddish anymore.
Is it a living language?
And that was a conver--
you do?
- My parents do.
- It's rare, though, right?
- Yeah, it's rare.
It's smaller.
And I couldn't let go
of Hebrew, Yiddish.
I was like, they both
need to be in there.
They both need to live
and exist together.
And I think that has
to do with looking
at a lot of the terrain of
some of the writers and travel
writers inside of the
archives that I was looking at
and who reigned supreme in a way
inside of the narrative, inside
of the narrative of the
archive that I was looking at.
- Well, I think this
jumps very nicely
to this idea of landscape.
And the way you
describe language
is really a form of embodying
a landscape in a different way,
about bringing different areas
of the globe into one sight,
thinking about Cambridge as a
global sight in and of itself,
thinking about the
internationalism of this UN
conference of the 1980s.
And this sort of goes back
to the original invitation
where I invited you to
come to do performances
on the Cambridge
Common, thinking
about this overarching
project about how we can bring
performance into public
art contexts that
were about this notion
of connectivity.
The Cambridge Common,
as a lot of us
who live here or have lived
here for the last several years
know that it's been under
renovation for three years--
and then they opened it up.
And we're like, oh,
there's new pathways.
That's great.
Wow, that took a long time.
But it's very beautiful.
So we must celebrate it.
And so what better way to do
so than with real avant-garde
practices.
And knowing your
past work at MoMA
and your other work
at the High Line
thinking about that as
an artist that you've
worked with archives as
a performative material
in and of itself as
a score, as a script.
You became the immediate
artist to invite.
And of course Radcliffe
as a neighbor-- thinking
about these notions
of connectivity,
how to bring them, as
Yukkio so nicely mentioned,
thinking about the archive
that's here in the Schlesinger,
here at Radcliffe, out into
the comment, which is so close,
yet psychologically and
logistically a fairly different
space at the same time.
So I don't know if
you want to talk
a little bit about that next
iteration of this project
because the really beautiful
gallery installation
that you've opened tonight--
and then later on
in about a month,
we'll start doing performances,
which will have a relationship
but fairly different
at the same level.
- I really have to thank
Deena and Yukkio and Meg
and Becky and Sean, again, and
Jen for their patience with me
because I tackle a few
different types of practices,
it takes me a while to--
I'm like a hawk.
I oversee.
I look over a landscape.
And then I slowly start
to pinpoint-- that's it.
It's like a ping.
I recognize that that's what's
the most important thing that
should come up or that's what's
the most important topic.
And so they've really let
me have a very fertile time
in the archive.
So I originally planned
on producing more
like a tour in the Commons.
First, we were
thinking of movement.
And then I sort of
settled in on a score,
a tour inside of the Commons.
But then we had this
really interesting moment
where we went to the
Cambridge Historical Society.
And it really changed my whole
perspective of the Commons
because one thing that
the young man said who--
he basically has
resurrected the Commons.
Or is he like main
gatekeeper of the Commons?
- Debatable.
But I think it's also
great that you called
Charlie Selvin a young man.
I think he'll be very
excited to hear that.
They've been varied
in the last 30 years.
It's been a very carefully
maintained landscape,
historicized very carefully so.
So we had a lot of
conversations about why
the Common feels so lonely.
It has a very empty quality.
I think people come and go.
It has a very
commuter feel to it.
But it had a history in the 60s
of being a radical gathering
sight.
That's where people
came to protest.
That's where you would go
if you wanted to protest.
Now when people go to protest--
I see a lot of people
on the front hall
of City Hall on Mass.
Ave. They go to Boston.
I don't know if
anybody protested
in the last several months
in January on the Common.
It's very quiet.
And so there was this question
that we were bringing up.
And when you went to visit
it, why is it that way?
And so there were
multiple answers.
Some people said getting
gathering permits were
really difficult suddenly.
And then at the Cambridge
Historic Society,
they were like, no,
people just stopped
asking to use the space.
So there was a bit of a
question of what happened.
And they actually had
renovated the Common
in the 70s to allow for
a greater gathering.
And then their experience
at the Historic Society
and in the city--
they said, well,
people just stop doing it
like after a certain point
in the early 70s.
People weren't gathering
to protest anymore.
And it just fell out
of the everyday action.
- Well, it also fell
out because I guess--
I don't think folks can
afford to stay in Cambridge
and live here and claim it.
And that was the my main
takeaway from the experience.
It's a transient
community in a way,
which is very similar to MoMA.
That's a smaller community
but in the sense that--
it seems as though.
I don't live here.
I know there are people who've
lived here for many years
and are probably
in the audience.
But from what
Charlie was saying,
it seems as though
people live here
for a time to continue
their education
and maybe start families.
But then they move elsewhere.
So you don't have this sense
of ownership of this space.
And that's what
really stuck to me.
And the project that
I'm doing is not
by any means owning the space.
But I hope that it at least
leaves an imprint on people's
memories of this space.
So it's going to be six
women inside of the space
responding to the
exhibition through text,
through spoken
word, and through--
well, we have wind instruments
and string instruments
and through classical and jazz.
So I hope to create a sound
environment and also a text
based environment that has some
movement and some color that
resonates with the installation.
But that also leaves an imprint
of one way to use the space.
- There's so much there.
It's once again this complex
layering in the after lives
that you imagined
for the characters,
that you kind of
will into being.
And the way different components
of your artistic practice
really mutually
inform one another.
In conclusion, I
think we'd just like
to point out that Xaviera
is a remarkable wordsmith
in her use of language.
And we heard about
the soaring hawk.
But another way that
she describes her method
is the hungry worm,
the hungry worm
that burrows through archives.
That's not an image that
librarians and archivists
like you hear too often.
But it's remarkably effective.
And she's effectively
burned a hole
through many interesting kind of
collections, collections here.
And another word
that will really
whet your appetite
for the gallery itself
is that of the maximalist--
that you are a maximalist
in your approach
to space in the way you've
conceived of the gallery.
And it's kind of the
environment itself.
And I think that's something
that people will immediately
grasp when they enter
into the gallery itself.
And so with that, I'd
like to invite everybody
to join us in the
reception at Byerly Hall
to witness the Xaviera's
exhibition and the reception.
Before we go, I'd like
to thank again once again
Xaviera Simmons and Deena
Deitsch for this conversation
and Xaviera for the exhibition.
Thank you so much.